if we're going to fit another Earth
anywhere in our solar system our best
betat is somewhere between our planet
and Mars our Earth is on the inner edge
of the Solar System's habitable zone and
with Mars closer to the outer edge
anything past it might be a little too
cold for a species like
ours let's imagine another Earth that's
close enough to our own so that its
inhabitants are comfortable the prospect
of two planets sharing the same orbit is
possible but it wouldn't last forever
eventually the gra gravitational
interaction between both planets would
either cause the two of them to collide
or one would end up pushing the other
one towards the Sun and we'd be back to
just one Earth I hope it's ours but
don't let that scare you it's possible
that two planets could coorbit in
harmony for billions of years before
anything bad happened another
possibility is a binary Planet system in
which Two Earths of comparable size
could have separate orbits with one
orbiting the other